hey Morgan how you doing oh wow oh my
gosh
you're on
okay can you hear me okay yeah what do
you got for me tonight
yeah um
you know what I'm not quite sure I think
this is just my first time joining I
guess maybe I'm just curious did you
have a question yeah I think I have one
coming okay um I think I'm just curious
where you stand in relation to the topic
that you posted
in relation to
yeah the topic that you posted which one
uh if feminists were honest uh yeah yeah
did you watch the start of the show yeah
I did
that's where I stand
did you need some clarity on one of the
points or
[Music]
um
I did hear a lot of the points that were
made by the women
um
I guess just from your authentic View
what is here
not so much stance on the points that
they made
um they just
I guess I would say of feminism all
around my idea is that
you probably lean a little bit more
against it
from what I understand
well look I mean
there was a point to feminism
there was a point to feminism you know
like at one point in history right like
women wanted to vote so they kind of got
together and they they got that and they
wanted this and then they wanted that
and they got that yeah sure I don't
think there's anything that women don't
get today that men get and in fact many
people would argue that women have
significant advantages over men and you
know I was once asked you know if you
could um
if you could come back Rich you know if
you were you know if I could take take
away your life and you could come back
you know again tomorrow in a new body
would you come back as a man or a woman
and I said you know what in today's
world I would come back as a beautiful
woman
oh my because it's much easier for women
to navigate though now of course I would
know the things that I know right now
you know that's the way that I'm looking
at it is you know do I get to know what
I get to know right now sort of thing
but the whole problem with feminism I
mean like as you heard is that it's all
it's all built around the fields it's
all built around
you know I I'm a victim and that's the
biggest problem with it is for you to be
a feminist you have to adopt a victim
mindset and for you to have a victim
mindset you have to have an oppressor
and if you have an oppressor that's
somebody that you don't like and who's
the oppressor it's always the guy
that's why you hear things like misogyny
and the patriarchy and they make up all
these stories about women making less
money for the same jobs that guys do but
if that was true then corporations would
hire only women to do the job so it just
becomes like a wingy whiny sort of thing
you see what I'm saying Morgan
yeah and I I hear you it's definitely a
battle on both sides for some reason why
do you ask are you a feminist no no
what do you think of feminism
I think if I answered directly I would
say I don't think of feminism
but if I answered to answer your
question
I would probably say I'm pretty close to
how you feel about it
there's some benefits to it
um throughout the history
I think in the context of relationship
it can be more damaging than good well
look I mean if you want a strong
masculine guide I don't think very many
strong masculine men which is what most
women seem to want anyway would put up
with a bossy disagreeable woman that is
going to play the victim card all the
time right
um they just tend to avoid them so is it
good for relationships not really but
that's where we are today
yeah
yeah it's cool
yeah no I mean it just there wasn't too
much to say it's my first time here and
I appreciate you explaining to me
when you think about it was really clear
all right sounds good thanks Morgan yeah
take care see ya hey guys I really hope
that you enjoyed that short clip if you
did consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out